don't push this but because that would
set off the bomb immediately and we'll
all be dead now repeat back what I just
said Congress no that's the button up
will kill everyone try again
Conkel mm-hmm oh good
uh-huh okay No does anybody have any
tape out there I want to put some tape
over the dead but nobody has any tape
not a single person has paint you have
an atomic bomb in your bag if anybody's
gonna have taken to you I have to do it
for you wasting a lot that's a really
bad sign
[Music]
when you
in your arms sometimes don't let me go
there are two types of things in the
universe
those are dance those who do not
I get it yes I am a dancer Cory is not
you just need to find a woman who is
pathetic like you thanks buddy do you
need a huh
no no I do not oh I thought I said no
you're welcome
I'm high on the lady
you